i would rather have a solution that i
can get uh
ninety percent of the marketplace to get
an 80 win
rather than have five percent of the
marketplace get a 100 win
[Music]
i uh slept like a cherub which is a
small angel baby
uh last night my gosh i feel like a
human being um and so i wanted to
bring you a question that layla asked me
yesterday and i thought that would be a
good podcast topic she was like
what would you actually do like right
now you're like well like if you had if
you were you know roll back the time
clock and this had happened when we had
our six uh gems like what would your
actual what would you do
to uh approach this and what would your
play be and so i wanna i wanna first
uh just at least say with my big
disclaimer here is that
uh something that i don't discuss a lot
but i think is worth mentioning
is that the advice that i give in
general
i try to cater to the audience that i'm
speaking to
if i ran a gym i would probably run it
somewhat differently than what we
espouse
and that is because i am not you and you
are not me
and so i would rather have a solution
that i can get
uh ninety percent of the marketplace to
get an 80
win rather than have five percent of the
marketplace get 100 win
um and i've run my business that way and
i think that is why we've been
uh really successful is because it's the
same thing with like a weight loss
program like if i can get
if i could get you know 90 of people to
have a great result
uh rather than you know 10 of people to
have a
crazy crazy result then i would rather
serve than 90.
um elon musk even talks about this he's
like i'd rather do
a good amount for a ton of people rather
than a lot for a very small amount
um and so we've taken the same approach
in terms of how we
uh you know like when we make offers all
my focus is like how can i make the best
offer that anyone can sell
right um how can i make a sales process
it's so easy anyone can do it
not necessarily like like for me i'd be
selling high ticket over the phone all
day long
right but a very small small segment
could actually do that successfully at
scale so that's my first disclaimer now
that being said
this is exactly what i would do um if my
gyms
you know were were in the midst of this
uh
you know covid stuff so first off
uh i would get out of the leases that i
have
now independent of of because there's
some people were like well we're going
to get out of this sooner or later i
have no idea
but what i know is just opportunity if i
have the opportunity to
to to flip my facilities in an
environment where i'm being encouraged
by both government
and my uh clients to make the flip and
remain open
uh then i'm going to take that
opportunity and
flip to a more profitable model right
like we're giving we're being given
permission
in this instance to do that with zero
repercussions it's even being
encouraged and so the first thing is i
would take all six i have my recurring
base of members
and i would flip them to remote now then
i would try and cut
um all of the rent uh for each of those
locations maybe even get out of the
lease
i would likely just try and negotiate
three to six months of free rent see how
it shakes out
but likely um this is what i'm saying i
would do you don't need to do this
all right i'm saying like this is how i
would this is how i would play my cards
all right and so what would happen is
let's say each of those gyms is at 30
000 a month right
uh in in recurrent just efts not running
cash flow nothing else not supplement
just like
they're doing 30 000 a month cool so now
i've got 180 000 a month that i have in
recurring
now let's be realistic let's say 25 of
those people drop off because
it's not an owner operated facility i've
got staff they don't care as much
they're not
rubbing bellies and kissing babies the
way i would if i were at a single
location
um and so let's say i lose 25 so that
means i lose roughly you know 45 000 off
that
um i think no
40 yeah right 40ish right
so lose 40 thousand on that so now i'm
down to like 140-ish or 135.
uh per month that's my recurring nun
okay
there's a lot of cash there all right
then i would take my best trainer
at each facility the guy the guy or gal
who cared the most who was the most
engaged with members who was the most
upbeat the most positive um and truly
cared about
uh keeping them and i might have to take
two at each facility if there's too many
for one person to handle that's fine
uh the rest of my personnel would be
considered non-essential because in this
new model they would not be able to
provide value
all right that's what i would do all
right so i've got let's see we got six
that means i've got
12 staff that i'm keeping on to maintain
a hundred and thirty five thousand
dollars in recurring revenue per month
now let's say
conservatively i pay each of these
people three thousand dollars a month
right to stay at home now that's a great
for some of these guys that might
actually be
a big pay jump from what they were doing
in person cool
so now they're making 3 000 a month
staying home to
just provide accountability all right
that is it
so big big thing here now like at gym
launch what we're doing is we have
um we just so i'm kicking this off today
uh starting on monday
we're running 16 remote workouts per day
basically
every hour during the normal workday uh
there's going to be a class that's being
held and that way
all of our gyms can cut their overhead
and just have all of those workouts as
fulfillment for their online clients
right and so now they don't even have to
staff that stuff it's already been taken
care of centrally
by all of us so all of our gyms can
participate that cut their over even
further right
now rewind back to the six gems so step
one i'm gonna get out of the leases that
i can because
because right now uh you have a pretty
good opportunity to be able to break
leases
uh and or at the very least to get three
to six months of free rent
uh right now so that's one two i would
flip
um my my recurring revenue into uh
remote which would be nutrition and
accountability primarily i'd have the
the workouts that are being done if i
have 12 trainers i can say each of you
guys are responsible for one workout
a day that's it that's one every hour
and that allows
all of my people to participate in a
session at any given time but it's not
that hard because each of them can do it
from home
right and the whole point is that like
i'd love to say it's gonna be from the
gym but
reality if you're getting quarantined
you might not be able to even go to the
gym so
and most of the clients are even
consuming this from their homes and so
it makes sense to have a trainer that's
from home not a big deal
so that's that's what i have on the
workout part
big big caveat here no one cares about
the workouts if you're selling over the
phone you can get workout apps online
you know like uh
you know beachbody and kayleitzin's got
a sweat app like there's all these other
apps that are like
10 to 20 a month that have probably
better already pre-existing stuff so
you're not going to win on the workout
front right
you're gonna win on the accountability
and the service that's how we've always
won and that's how we need to keep like
remember the rules haven't changed your
workouts never matter they don't matter
now
right what matters is the relationship
that you have these people that they
feel like someone is checking in on them
right they pay for you to pay attention
that's how it works
all right so i have my 12 trainers let's
say i'm paying them 3 000 a month so i'm
paying 36 000 a month in overhead
for those trainers right and the only
thing they have to do every day is one
workout
and then reach out to the customers so
make sure that they are
uh being taken care of making sure that
their head space is good making sure
that they're not going to the pantry and
rating it and getting cookies every day
make sure making sure that they attend
one of the workouts that is what they do
all day now that's it that's all they
have to do
all right now overnight by doing this
i have a hundred thousand a month that's
left
over in all profit holy smokes
that's a pretty good deal but wait now
what do i do with my time right
so my time would be focused um the other
thing that i would ask them to do
is uh i would dedicate their first two
hours of the day
every day to doing 100 cold reach outs
all right they want to pay for
themselves cool
100 cold reach outs what you do is if
you have someone who who's
who's interested you book them on my
calendar i'll close them
all right so i'm going to fill my day up
with uh
appointments that my team my 12 people
doing reach outs
are going to set for me all right and
then i'm going to close beyond that
um i'm going to start turning on cold
traffic and i'm going to run because
right now
in this hypothetical environment which
is the real environment currently uh
lead costs are like 50
to 75 off it's nuts right i've never
seen anything like this it's crazy
um and so we would be scheduling uh
phone calls
to sell and so my trainer's day looks
like this first two hours of the day
all they're doing is doing cold reach
outs they get their daily 100 you give
me 100 reach outs that's what you owe me
all right get me one schedule today i
don't care just give me one schedule
today
all right what are they going to say
they're going to say hey name
do you know anybody who's trying to stay
in shape during the quarantine who
doesn't want to get make turn their
sweatpants into yoga pants by the end of
this
ha right whatever now when you say that
all of a sudden the people who are
responding are like oh this person's not
fishing they're asking genuinely
if i know anybody right and now more
than ever people have a lot of good will
that they want to help out other small
business owners like that is definitely
the zeitgeist of this moment
zach has a german word for the general
vibe of an era
anyway so people are trying to help out
small business owners so if you're
asking like that you're not even
soliciting them
you're just saying hey do you know
anybody and a lot of times i'm like you
know i'm trying not to lose weight
perfect or gain weight perfect let's get
you booked for a call we have a totally
remote thing to make sure that you stay
healthy etc right
so their first two hours they're doing
the daily reach outs then they're doing
all the recess to their existing
customers that they're maintaining
right and then one hour of the day
they're uh required to do their workout
now
most of the time you'd want to have your
your trainers are working out anyways at
home so it's like just
record it like have fun with it right
and then that way
all of my people can actually have more
sessions than they ever had in person so
i'm adding value then from what i used
to have
they have more availability than we've
ever had they have more variety because
they probably have access to trainers
that they couldn't have had access to
before
all right and it's also my best coaches
so it's like you know we all know
we've got a couple coaches who run stuff
and if somebody use news coming in you
probably want to put them with jessica
and not eric
right you're like no jessica's awesome
don't put it in eric's as her first
session right maybe
maybe save that for some of the later
people who already like us right so
those are the trainers who are going to
be getting those at-home workouts
big picture again big reminder no one
cares right no one cares about the
workouts they only care about the
accountability all right
so if i flip my gyms right i renegotiate
my leases i push them out or i break
them
i take my recurring i would get into 100
remote
i would let go of non-essential
personnel or not who are not generating
revenue or keeping revenue through
fulfillment right
they're generating revenue in their
first two hours a day by getting new
calls the rest of their day
they're focused on doing the fulfillment
for the for the clients that they
already have and maintaining that eft
and recurring um
they're filling back the bucket because
i'm going to be doing the sales because
in in a time of strife
i'm going to do what i do know how to do
best and make it rain right and so
the people who are not going to be able
to succeed are the ones who don't want
to roll up their sleeves and get dirty
if you're the best salesman at your gym
then you should sell that's what you
should be doing right
and then they do their one workout a day
so that's what trainers have to do three
things
reach outs to to to get new customers
reach out to existing customers make
sure they know we're paying attention
and then finally that they're doing
one workout a day which they should be
doing for themselves anyways they're
just gonna record it
awesome boxes checked all right my day
is gonna be making sure that we're
marketing and filling the bucket back
up all right that's it that's my day all
right so i'm marketing and taking sales
calls i'm taking sales calls from paid
traffic taking sales calls from
from outbound i'm taking sales calls all
day long that is what my job is to make
it rain
and feed the machine all right that is
what i would have done
um if i had been in that situation or in
this situation
i'm not necessarily saying you do that
i'm telling you what i would have done
and that would be the play that i would
do because it would give me permission
to overnight transform six facilities
into one
massive recurring revenue stream that's
100 remote that is high
higher profit margin for fulfillment and
i will say what i said yesterday but
i'll say it again
uh so hopefully it sinks in is that just
because this has changed does not mean
it's bad
right eight months ago i walked through
all the math about why having a remote
fulfillment
is a better solution there's a reason
people like going online right
there are better margins right there are
the thing is is that a lot of people
felt like for some reason that that was
bad
that's okay but now people are being
forced to do it doesn't mean it's bad it
actually makes more money and now we're
getting permission from the government
and from society
to do this for ourselves so i would take
that opportunity
and uh run with it so that's my rec not
my recommendation excuse me that's what
i would have done
uh you can take that for which you will
but that is exactly what i would have
done step by step
that's how it broken out my trainers
that's what i would have done with my
overhead
that's what i would have redefined their
responsibilities as and then beyond just
lead them through the crisis
um i would also try and paint a vision
or for a better future
it's like guys you liking this you're
staying at home you can work out
whenever you want
um you're just actually getting people
good results because we're making sure
that they're just staying accountable
and they need us the most
right and one small note that i want to
add to this
when you're selling or when you're
talking to customers
everyone right now is at the airport so
if you've noticed everyone at the
airport is always just like
immediately a three out of ten three out
of five stressed right they're
already at six out of ten stress levels
what people want is to feel good all
right and so that's gonna
and so when you get on the phone if you
wanna sell right
you gotta make them feel good like the
fundamentals have not changed it's just
you got a little bit more resistance
when you're starting
because they're already at a negative
point they're not at neutral
most people are now going to be a little
bit negative because they're quarantined
they got their kids around they feel
like [ __ ] they're smelly
they're you know they they feel sloppy
and bloated because they're eating
cookies all day
right and uh you know they're uncertain
about the future what they want from you
what your employees want from you what
your clients want from you
and what your prospects when you get on
the phone with them want from you is one
word
hope all right so you have to be the
hopeless [ __ ]
that exists all right and the way that
you have hope is that you have optimism
about what you are willing to do
to endure and as long as you know that
you're willing to endure
just about anything to get through this
then you have confidence and certainty
in the fact
that you will get through this and you
can you can uh convey that
conviction to your prospects to your
team
and to your to your customers because
that's what they're going to want they
like right now therapy is blowing up
life coaching is blowing up
in terms of like growth tons of people
want life coaches tons of people want
therapists right now because they're
stressed out of their minds
and so if you're looking for more ways
to provide value
someone will buy after how you've made
them feel
from the first 15 minutes of the phone
call the first 15 minutes is just like
caring about them throwing them some
love making them feel good about like
hey we're going to get through this no
worries
right they want to be around more of
that they want more of that feeling
the fact that you're going to sell them
weight loss and that's going to be the
vehicle that you monetize
is almost secondary to how you will make
them feel in that moment because they're
just going to want to feel more of that
and so that goes for your trainers
reminding them dude
like we're just trying to make people
feel good right now all right we're
trying to get people through this
like if we can get them to put down the
cookies and move a little bit they're
probably going to feel better and if
that's what that's what our value is
right now then that's what it's going to
be
all right so that is what i would do
step by step um if i have my gym drink
covered right now
um i make no recommendations you are all
grown as individuals and make your own
decisions for yourself but that is what
i would do so anyways
hope you have an amazing wednesday keep
rocking you can make it through this
um you just gotta want it all right lots
of love catch you guys soon
[Music]
you